welcome back to teram Gardens today
we'll be exploring the fury and
fascinating Tabasco pepper this vibrant
chili is not just known for its iconic
rolling hot sauces but also for its
unique growing characteristics and uses
did you know that Tabasco peppers are
one of the few Chili Peppers whose
fruits are juicy rather than dry on the
inside this unique quality gives Tobasco
Peppers their distinctive flavor and
heat profile which is why they are the
key ingredient in the famous tobasco
sauce the Tobasco pepper has an
intriguing history originating in the
Mexican state of Tabasco these peppers
were cultivated by indigenous peoples
for centuries before gaining popularity
worldwide the pepper was first
commercially grown in the United States
by Edmund mcki on Avery Island Louisiana
in the mid 19th century mcki used the
peppers to create his now famous hot
sauce which he first marketed in 1868
this sauce catapulted the Tobasco pepper
into International Fame cementing its
place in culinary history Tabasco
Peppers plants are small and bushy
typically reaching of about 2 to 4 ft
the peppers themselves are small
measuring about 1 to 2 in in length they
start out green and mature to a bright
vibrant red though some varieties may
turn yellow or orange the peppers grow
in an upward orientation which is quite
different from many other pepper
varieties that hang downward this
upright growth habit is a distinctive
characteristic of Tabasco peppers and
adds an ornamental appeal to
Gardens if you're thinking about growing
Tobasco Peppers there are a few
conditions you'll need to keep in mind
these Peppers thrive in warm humid
climates some similar to their native
environment they prefer well draining
soil that is rich in organic matter with
a pH level between 5.5 and 7.5 to get
started plant your seeds indoors about 8
to 10 weeks before the last expected
Frost they require temperatures of
around 75 to 80° f for optimal
germination once the ceilings are about
6 in tall and the outdoor temperature
consistently stays above 60° they can be
transplanted outside make sure to space
them about 18 to 24 in apart to give
them Room to Grow Basco Peppers also
need plenty of sunlight at least 6 hours
a day regular watering is crucial
especially during flowering and fruiting
stages but avoid water logging the soil
as this can lead to root rot companion
planting can benefit Tabasco pepper
significantly good companion plants for
Tabasco Peppers include basil carrots
onions and tomatoes these plants help to
tear Pest and can improve soil quality
around your Tobasco pepper plants avoid
planting Peppers near fennel as this can
stunt the Pepper's growth May gos are
also excellent companions as they can
naturally repel nematodes which are home
for the pepper plants one special
behavior of Tobasco pepper plants is
their resistance to many common pests
and diseases making them relatively easy
to grow however they can be susceptible
to aphids white flies and spider mites
especially in green houses or in indoor
environments regular inspection and
natural pest control methods like neem
oil or insy todal soap can help manage
the issues Tobasco peppers are also
known for their continuous fruit
production throughout the growing season
providing a steady Harvest While most
commonly known for their roles in hot
sauces Basco peppers have other culinary
uses as well they can be used fresh in
Salsas stews and even pickled beyond
their culinary uses Tobasco peppers have
some medicinal properties they contain
capsacin a compound known for its pain
relief properties and potential benefits
in boosting metabolism and reducing
inflammation capson is also the reason
behind the Pepper's heat which can vary
between 30,000 to 50,000 scoval heat
units making them modly hot Tabasco
peppers are a fascinating plant to grow
whether you're a seasoned Gardener or a
hot sauce enthus iast looking to
cultivate your ingredients with their
unique characteristics vibrant colors
and various uses they are a great
addition to any Garden we hope you
enjoyed your learning about the Tobasco
pepper today don't forget to like share
and subscribe for more garding tips and
plant profiles thanks for watching and
happy planning